while the ride-hailing giant uber
battled chaos and a whole lot of
controversy this year competitor live
made some big gains the company has
added service to 150 US markets in 2017
so that makes it available in more than
350 areas across the country more than
80 percent of people in the United
States can now hail a ride on their
phones John Blackstone got a lift from
lifts co-founder and president that's
John Zimmer to learn his keys to success
traffic is a plague in cities across the
country morning John when I went for a
ride in San Francisco with lyft
president and co-founder John Zimmer we
got stuck in a typical Jam look at all
these cars they're individuals driving
themselves and no one else sharing the
ride with them ride-sharing has
propelled lyft and its larger competitor
uber into multi-billion dollar companies
both launched in San Francisco just a
couple of years apart around the same
time you were starting lyft there were
some guys across town starting another
company yeah I heard about that it's
actually growing a lot faster than yours
so they actually started with private
cars limos a couple years before us so
they had a footprint but before them we
launched a peer-to-peer transportation
which is kind of people using their own
personal cars and we're now the
fastest-growing ride share service in
the United States and are taking market
share from from those other guys those
other guys uber have spent months
dealing with a series of scandals that
led to the recent ouster of CEO Travis
kalanick a study of credit card
transactions shows uber losing market
share as lyft gains lyft says it now has
30% of the US market what's been the
biggest challenge that you faced there's
always been doubt behind our our set of
values taking care of our drivers taking
care of our passengers was really
important and many people said that's
going to hold you back that other
competitors to it too aggressive and we
said these are two different things
we're aggressively pursuing our values
of taking care of people and and that is
actually good for business and I think
finally people are starting to realize
that
in 2016 lyft provided more than a
hundred sixty-two million rides three
times more than in 2015
growth this year is up a hundred forty
two percent recently you've told the
people here don't gloat yeah I think
it's important look anything that's
happening with a competitor doesn't have
an impact on our drivers our passengers
and the people here upstairs we have the
product and engineering team we first
met simmer in 2012 that his startup
called
Zuma ride we're trying to make history
and by building a new form of
transportation you know there was canals
there was railroad there was highways
and there was M rot in 2012 Zimride had
a couple of dozen workers now lyft has
1,700 employees more than 700,000
drivers as Zimmer sees it the drivers
are making good use of cars that would
otherwise just be parked we have two
hundred fifty million cars in the United
States that are parked in ninety six
percent of the time this is completely
inefficient the city of San Francisco
says that one of the impacts of lyft and
uber has been to create more traffic in
the city yes we've seen that that
reporting I think that the opportunity
here is to make traffic go away and so
we believe we are doing that in
instances and if there are cases where
we're not and that's based on data then
we're gonna work with the local
government we're gonna fix it both uber
and lyft see self-driving cars in their
future lyft is developing technology and
partnership with Google General Motors
and Jaguar Land Rover we think that in a
few years you'll be subscribing to a
miles plan on lift the way you were
subscribed to a minutes plan on AT&T or
Verizon or t-mobile
we've already disrupted the taxi
industry are you going up against the
automobile industry in a way now as well
we're really focused on the customer and
what customers want and providing that
experience if that means we can provide
a better experience than the alternative
then we're gonna do that and Zimmer
practices what he preaches when he gave
me a lift he borrowed a car I currently
don't own a car and I carpool to work
with my co-founder in the
mornings so you can get along in a major
city like San Francisco without a car
absolutely and that's the future that
you see yeah I think so I think it's
gonna free up a lot of space within our
cities it's gonna save people money
there's no doubt John Zimmer is a
ride-sharing visionary but for now just
like the rest of us he can still end up
in gridlock for CBS this morning John
Blackstone San Francisco ride-sharing
visionary and appears to be a really
good guy love his no gloat policy don't
you I was gonna say yeah yeah absolutely
with all the different uber and Kalinin
yeah don't just just focus on what
you're doing and just do it well I like
aggressively pursuing our values of
taking care of people you go all about
the customer right nicely done it